janvier la disparition d'une très jeune
adolescente près de kehl elle s'est
probablement suicidé tout comme son ami
dans le corps a été retrouvé en milieu
de semaine ce mal de vivre l'une d'entre
elles l'avait raconté dans son journal
intime sur internet ce blog était
constitué d'une trentaine de pages où
elle indiquait son intention d'en finir
stéphanie davoigneau pourquoi tu nous as
quittés sitôt sur les murs du collège de
noémie 15 ans ses camarades expriment
leur peine comme ils peuvent
le corps de l'adolescente a été retrouvé
avant-hier elle avait disparu depuis
mardi avec son ami clémence dans une
lettre elle indiquait vouloir se
suicider clémence elle reste introuvable
ses copains se rappelle qu'elle avait
souvent des pensées et des jeux morbide
je possède je fais bien thatchérien ont
parlé un petit peu de soleil se fait
tout en les v ux 11i c'était peut-être
s'y met aussi
mais j'en connais pas au sérieux
non non ont pris plusieurs qui font ça
dans le lycée ne compromettait pour
faire pareil que les êtres
automutilation le proviseur confirme il
décrit une adolescente qui se cherche
mais pas plus que les autres elle a une
façon d'être gay c'est une jeune tony
que souriante dynamique pleine de
ressources parfois un peu trop et puis à
d'autres moments une peut-être une
difficulté qu'ont certains jeunes à ceux
avoir plus de difficultés à se
construire se construire à se projeter
dans l'avenir
autre appel au secours les messages
laissés sur son blog sorte de journal
intime diffusée sur le net que les
adolescents consultent rarement les
adultes
cinq jours avant sa disparition elle
écrivait finalement j'ai abandonné et
lâchement je me suis suicider personne
n'a répondu
c'est là on touche à peu aux limites de
l'internet c'est dans la mesure où il ya
une illusion peut-être de communication
on croit que ce message peut être
entendu et puis la toile est tellement
est tellement vaste que finalement il
n'y a pas de réponse sur la plage du cap
gris nez
les recherches se poursuivent pour
retrouver des traces de clémence et
comprendre ce qui est vraiment arrivé
aux deux adolescentes